hey everyone it's my vatos and welcome
to the order flows market analysis for
September 27 2017 I want to probably
cover a little bit of the 26 on a
Tuesday as well a little bit behind I'm
posting some of these videos so I'll
sort of do a two and one I promise I
won't post another picture video of my
son in school but spicing Li that video
got more likes than my analysis videos
um so maybe I should stick to that
instead of market analysis but Before we
jump in a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making it a
type of investment decision futures
train contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor and investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle an only risk capital should be
used for training only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past reports is not necessarily
indicative of future results tools using
this presentation by the order phone's
trader volume footprint chart and the
Delta scalper and it might talk about
one or two other little indicators here
and there as well so let's let's get
started okay I'll try and be quick today
so this is yesterday's actually the 26
this is Tuesday in the bonds alright and
very tight range coming into the morning
session Tuesday morning we start selling
off we got a three in a row right here
you don't get the pullback for ideal
entry and then you start making some new
lows here down here you got price
rejecter and that's it okay you got a
small negative Delta still got the green
candle okay you do get a little bit of a
bounce up about four or five ticks then
you come down here into this new low at
1026 this is this is the classic the
divergence and a ratio divergence ratio
next bar you also have a ratio and you
got the Delta scalper giving you a buy
but you got a nice little move up here
of about eight ticks more or less then
you just sort of go sideways here you
got a nice stacked imbalance you do come
back down sort it honestly test this low
but you get a few ticks off the low
before you put in another push higher
and then you sort of close out the day
then you go into the next day and you
sell off Wednesday morning during the
European session you sell off quite
dramatically not going to get into the
whys but anyway at 4:00 in the morning
you hit your low you got your point of
control towards the bottom you've got
your divergence you got your ratio again
it's go time I said is the easiest trade
you can take with order flow and what
happens is you get a nice little pop up
over the next two bars you know I'm
about six seven ticks right there and
then you go sideways this is the Delta
surge coming in here giving you a sell
signal you do go lower I don't I don't
necessarily like that signal on that bar
you get down here you have a divergence
no ratio we get down here you got a
divergence and a ratio and you got the
Delta scalper as well so you got a few
things going for you unfortunately you
make a new low you hit this new low
you've got a divergence no ratio the
ratio though is twenty seven point seven
I have mine set at twenty eight but
again you know is it a line in the sand
no I mean if you're looking at twenty
seven point seven three you might be
willing to take it it just sort of went
sideways on the o here so it didn't
really work out that great you also got
a delta scalper we made a new little buy
a couple ticks so then you started
rallying up going you know I'll say
sideways your rally up and then you sort
of come off and you just sort of snake
into the rest of the day but I wanted to
talk about this alright this look at
this Delta okay it's easier when you're
looking at the candle so you're coming
down here alright you're coming down
quite nicely dramatic selling strong
negative Delta two thousand four hundred
seventeen hundred seven hundred then you
get a positive Delta here two eighty two
small Delta thirty-one small two thirty
seven two one seven then it starts
picking up again okay you can see how
the selling is as strong but it's
getting weaker it comes into this area
where people are happy to trade you know
trade is evenly distributed
you know buyers and sellers are happy to
transact at these prices and then the
selling comes in again and you can see
you can see it pick up again two one
seven four six to seven thirty seven two
thousand two thousand and what happens
is will sell off making new lows so the
signs were here is right in here
hey we can take out these loads we're
not gonna rally so you know if you're
long from this signal here and you're
staring at all these big strong negative
Delta's it you can be fairly confident
that it's it's not gonna rally I mean if
you got negative Delta a 2000 followed
by another barb negative Delta of 2000
chances are very small that it's going
to rally and what happens boom you sell
off into new lows from 12 all the way
down to just about double low and on
this initial move later you get down to
double low but you know that was I mean
that was classic Delta analysis right
there you know again if there's several
parts of order flow and if you just use
one of them in your analysis of trading
it'll put you ahead of a lot of other
traders so the next market we'll talk
about is five years again you know five
years is quite similar to the bonds
actually yesterday you know at your low
here at 7:54 what do you got you got
your ratio and divergence and what
happens is the market puts in a little
bit of a rally up you know from this low
here at 16 all the way up to 19 and a
half the previous day though I just that
goes step back here previous day on 26
you don't have you know anything to be
any reason to be buying these lows this
low or this low I mean do have the price
rejecter here this low I thought was
interesting this one at 10:26 I mean you
do have the Delta surge kicking off you
got some very nice buying imbalances and
you see the deltas increasing that's the
way you like it there's a rally yeah it
does but you know nothing nothing great
and then you get this bar here with the
very bearish bearish looking bar right
here with the point controller at the
top the bearish ratio and then you just
fall over you get down here again you
got a nice bullish ratio but you don't
have you know you don't have divergence
but why don't you have the divergence
well because you got very strong support
of mine this is what support of mine
looks like in the market to 7000 this
5000 and how do I know support a buying
well I know the Delta is negative so
when I see that that to me that's a sign
of support of buying because the market
popped back up on less volume on the off
as we're training back up and you can
see these imbalances over the next
couple of bars so that was that was on
the 26 so let's take a look at crude
over the last couple days really quick
here if I could find the right crude
chart I want my range chart up Melissa
Delta scalper and the crude what I want
is the footprint chart here we go there
was a couple I mean this was one where I
mean euro currency over the last couple
days just followed Delta scalper really
nice but I wanted to talk about where
was it and it was early and this this
move right here I thought this was this
is a classic like order flow analysis I
think so sorry about that no no I got
this lingering cough look at this okay
so you're coming down here you got
strong negative Delta's it kind of
lightning up here you got positive bar
negative Delta button green bar here
still got negative Delta here you got
the positive bar you got the divergence
no ratio Delta scalper kicking off in
this next bar this is actually a
transition of Altos transition it's hard
to see this yellow but this is what the
bottles transition looks like you're
seeing it really shifting from you know
a supply driven market to a demand
driven market then you can see it really
come in here with the stack buying
imbalances and we rally up if you get to
the swing high you got price rejector
here the next bar after the price
rejecter you have you got the single
print you got the ratio but you got the
Delta scalper kicking in and you sell
off down into new lows you bounce up a
little bit down into some new lows down
there you know off this low here that we
were hitting here just before 8 o'clock
on the 26 you do you get divergences but
and you got Delta scalper okay but they
don't really market doesn't really rally
you know that's that's not a good sign
so you got divergence divergence you
know earlier you had this divergence
excuse me at 4:00
right here at 7:51 801 divergence
divergence I'd be watching and see if
what's gonna happen if we test that low
if we break it if I go lower and you
what happens is you break it you know I
like it when you have multiple failed
divergences and strong selling look at
these deltas 1600 1600 as you're going
into new lows and it just sells off
quite dramatically from 80 all the way
down into the 44 you get down here and
what you got you got a divergence okay
oh and this is this buy again you know I
I'm not gonna say this one was classic
order flow it's not this one's gonna
take a little bit of a leap of faith but
there was a you got the divergence you
got some strong deltas coming in here
and it's all positive Delta's here you
know this one started out with negative
Delta ended up at positive Delta then
this one strong positive closing right
almost on its max Delta this one also
strong positive : losing closing almost
on its max Delta that's foolish foolish
behavior right there and the market
shoots up didn't yesterday on the 27th
what was there the only thing can't
remember top my head what was there that
was the most interesting thing to talk
about I think there was much yesterday
let's take a look at that low here and
we again what do you got this low you
got a ratio and divergence what else can
I say you know it happens you got
multiple imbalances in this bar multiple
imbalances in this bar multiple
imbalances in this bar if you're not
convinced that this mica starting put in
a rally then you know you should have
probably shouldn't be trading I mean the
markets telling you right you got your
ratio you got your divergence you got
three buy imbalances nother three buy
imbalances no there's free buying a
balance you got a delta surge all
systems go and what happens is the
market just sort of goes sideways and
then it starts putting in the rally you
know a little bit later but you know
here's the deltas scalp or give you the
sell but it came right back with the Buy
and it shut
excuse me it shot up but again the signs
were in here to be buying around the
7576 area and if you're patient enough
it got up above you know fifty to fifty
two bucks
let's take a look at e minis I'll deal
with the ten range chart as opposed to
the four range just because before rain
just got a lot of stuff ten range would
be a lot cleaner I think you just find
it here
[Music]
okay so again you know we'll go back a
couple days on this one as well go back
to the 26th and what do you got up here
on this high on the 26 you got a small
Delta only 2,265 Delta scalper giving
yourself next bar what happens you sell
down into new lows you know you come off
from what is that ninety seven area down
into the 93 area before you get a buying
signal here with the Delta scalper
you got inbound stacks selling and
balance followed by a stack buying
imbalance and in the market which is a
bullish shine and the market just
started rallied then I say rallied just
sort of was trading trending a little
bit higher until you came into just
before the cash closed well you see a
lot of selling coming in here you see
the multiple imbalances couple
imbalances in the next bar right headed
the cash closed and then you just sort
of close down here but then on 27th this
one here I thought this was a great sell
you got point control up near the top
and you got that shift in Delta all
right you went from a very strong
positive Delta right the bar before it
positive Delta 8000 very strong next
party continues he had positive Delta
most early in that bar 3481 very strong
and went from positive three four eight
one two finishing at minus four nine
three eight so that's a swing of which
is about 8,000 contracts where it went
from aggressive buying to aggressive
selling which is very bearish sign and
what happens is this market sells off
you know from this next bar around the
o2 area you come down in here make new
lows at 90 93 do you have any reason we
buying well you got a stack buying
imbalance off the low which I like
then my charts ended but you know I mean
you did have that
an opportunity as well there for me is
more of a you know if you can get short
at o2 and you're covering it down here
at 95 you don't need to trade and the
rest of the day but you could have
gotten long here even in an x-bar you
see the buying coming in here as well so
I mean you know it's one of these things
you ask yourself you know take trades in
context what does that mean take trades
in context well here you have a bar
negative Delta seven thousand two
hundred eighty five mint min Delta's
minus seven three six five up here you
have you know a strong Delta as well
minus seven three six four okay now you
know I know some people say we got this
big strong negative Delta you should get
short okay well you also have a big
strong negative Delta here does that
mean get short again here well you're
already you're treated into your law you
got the negative Delta you know where do
you want to be taking the trade based on
the strong negative note that somewhere
up here just off the high of the day or
down here at the low of the day that's
what I mean we're taking things in
context of the market um you know if
you're gonna be looking for a strong
negative Delta and you see it up here
near the highest he's probably gonna be
a little bit more potent than taking a
trade on strong negative Delta you know
at the low of the day so that was it in
the S&P s see if I get the euro currency
up here really quick I might just pull
up a chart of bar chart just just really
quick this is the Uni Renko chart of the
euro currency this is what the Dalton
scalper just take a look at you know cuz
you're all sold off quite nicely
got some nice signals mixed in here you
had some bad stickers when you get some
nice moves here you know from forty five
down to fifteen and even the next day
you get some nice little cells in here
nice cells and mice but let me just find
the see if I could find them just a
normal eight range euro currency chart
you know that will be it's here for the
day
well uh so I don't like I need the chart
I can't find it
well okay this is a footprint chart
we'll deal with that that's fine just go
back
okay so what do we got here now this one
again I'm not really looking at too much
here I'm just really looking for you
know some of the classic stuff right
ratio and divergence right here off this
low okay right there alright what else
you got
again you just got divergence here
nothing
Delta scalper giving you a sell their
racial divergence that one failed got a
ratio on divergence right here rallies
up to this area where you got the Delta
scalper giving you a sell there's a
delta scalper buy in this area I'll buy
a sell here anything else dr. scalper
sell there another sell here this was a
nice one market was moving pretty quick
at this time but it was a nice trade to
get going down into some new lows your
rally up off this low it's a delta
scupper sells nice little sell there
it's nice little buy they're not much
before also before it went against yeah
thing and that's it the one in the
morning I'm more interested in the main
session here's a cell doctor scalper
sell tested that area before it's sold
off a little bit then rallied you got a
cell here that didn't work out so you
had a cell here I just that failed yeah
by down here sort of went sideways on
you and that was about it
there's a nice little cell here as well
nice little cell here as well so I can I
want to keep this too long I got I still
got this darn sore throat so thanks for
watching this video and I'm starting to
get caught up on every video and if your
student overflows visit website and be
sure to subscribe to the channel the
order flow is calm click the button
below to subscribe to the YouTube
channel that's important because if you
subscribed and you know
more people that join the YouTube
channel keeps me going makes me want to
do more videos so thanks everyone have a
great day bye bye